for
[Music]
what
e
e e
okay so look see how this arm is doing
that
I'm making it gross now
see there that's in the powder because
I'm going this
way that's my angle deviation but
however I'm doing it I'm over here that
means my angle deflection goes which
way to my left so it goes
in and let his shoulder pass there pass
and let him hit your hand that's where
you project
[Music]
okay okay on the other one it's the same
thing he goes that way I let his
shoulder pass let this weight hit
there same
thing let it hit there
[Music]
is
right
again
e e
all right
so you and now so you projected them
away which is cool because you're going
to do you're going to do
Ur I mean you're going to DOI for the
ten con but it is
Ura and Ura is for when he's pushing on
me
or when he has gone
so you have to yield in the
UR and that yield happens here piss Ever
So
Soft
around meaning don't
go leave it there grab
it soften it soften it in that small
circle
not here it's going to soften so watch
his hand plot his hand in space
vertically and when I do the inward
spiral you're going it goes this way his
arm is longer now you
see that means it came towards me and
that's what I
also create the opening to get out you
can't hold
[Music]
that and in
that this hand is on the Y Line but when
I go around it
his hands now on the midline you
see now this hand can touch it and bring
it to the arm
[Music]
line boom it's on the Y Line Circle it's
on the in the the midline in takes over
from the
midline into the off
elbow on the mid
line you have to
yield but all right on the second
one you're going to have it here right
here it just it gets to be
bigger now now you can get out now
you're out then it rolls
under then it does does it not this hand
this does
it
[Music]
boom don't come in and grab yield with
that
Circle then the two do
it two
points move Look let see how his arm
comes backwards again plot his arm
about his hand his
face it's going to come back towards me
you
see because I'm doing
R I have to
he this way boom there he
is this
way this way
boom
bo my hand his contact Point comes to
that
midline this irrelevant
now here hand touch here this
[Music]
line let's do a one handed for now
all right so when I go here you you have
to stick here stick here don't shove
this down he'll fall out the
bottom you stick okay so I stick here I
stick here which means what what's my y
value it's it's matching his do you see
that so he tries to pull out it's stuck
it's stuck in there and now you start
adding the centrifugal energy right and
because I keep moving it forward the
bottom gets filled up right now if I'm
static he can't pull away pull that way
you can't pull away but he can go
under so that's why I'm
turning not not here here I'm turning
this constantly so as he tries to go
under he just is putting himself into
the braak
which means don't go here and maximize
this it's going to get under you need to
keep
him in the iades as you work at cental
centrifugal forces
is where you want to end up turn the
braak